[Music]
get 12 issues of the magazine plus a 20
pound amazon voucher for just 12 pounds
if it sounds too good to be true that's
because it is go to spectator dot co dot
uk
forward slash tv offer to take it up
now first covet case rates in bolton are
more than 10 times the english average
in bedford more than six the indian
variant of covet has been rising in
these areas leading to fears that the uk
could go the way of india
which saw a surge of cases resulting in
the dwindling of medical supplies
and hospitals being overrun is this new
strain which is thought to have
contributed to the virus getting out of
control
with outstanding questions about its
transmissibility
although of course problems with india's
vaccine rollout have played a major role
as well
so the question today is could that
happen here and are we going to see the
uk's long-awaited freedom day put on
hold
to discuss i'm joined now by ucl's
professor christina pagel
christina thank you for joining us on
spectator tv
we've gotten a sense over the past 24 to
48 hours that the prime
minister and his officials think
concerns over the indian variant
may have been a false alarm but you
disagree
i don't think we know yet whether it was
a a false alarm
or not certainly cases are still going
up
quite significantly um the latest data
from the uk covid conjunct
genetics consortium which sequences data
here
shows that it's about 35 of all cases
now sequenced
is this new variant um the welcome
sanger data which was released
on monday which updates weekly and just
takes community cases so remove stasis
from travel and surge testing
are up to 28 of cases so there's no
doubt that it's been going
up now the question is is growth slowing
are the measures that they put in place
working
and as we get more cases do we get a
better handle on how much more
transmissible it is
and it is very sensitive to it so i
think there is agreement that it's
more transmissible than the dominant
what's called the kent variant in the uk
but um it's kind of if it's only 10 more
then there probably won't be a big issue
this summer but if it's 50
more that could be a really big issue so
until we pin that down i think it's too
early to say whether it's a false alarm
so i've seen figures that say that the
indian variant is roughly 20
of the cases across england there you
cited 35
if it were significantly transmissible
or if we were in danger of seeing
exponential growth
why wouldn't this be reflected in the
national data
when actually it remains the case that
we're around 97
percent below the peak of cases and
deaths 99
below the peak yeah so that that 20
figure comes from the um cog the covid
genetics consortium website but that's
over the last two weeks
and so two weeks ago it was 15 and then
it went up to 30
so that's kind of the average of both of
them so over the last week it has gone
up further
um the reason cases have still been
going down is because the dominant
variant
so the kent variant that has been
declining so effectively you've had two
epidemics you've had one where cases are
going down
and one we're starting from much smaller
numbers is going up
and that's masking the rise of the
indian variant we saw exactly the same
thing in europe
in january and february when our variant
was becoming dominant there
and the old variant was dying out that
actually cases were coming down even
while the kent variant was increasing
so the question is can we can we delay
the increase of this variant long enough
and vaccinate enough people
so that we can we can actually continue
opening or not and we just and
i don't think we know that yet so we're
not yet at the situation where this
variant is dominant in england and until
it is you wouldn't expect it to start
driving overall numbers
but we have the vast vast majority of
the most vulnerable in the uk
vaccinated we now have 34 35 year olds
getting vaccinated well over 20 million
people have their
second jab uh so in terms of those who
would have been vulnerable last year
when the circumstances were different
we're in very different
territory now and cases are still at
rock bottom
hospitalizations deaths as well what's
the reason for not pushing ahead with
opening up
well it's certainly true i mean like the
vaccines are great
and if we didn't have the vaccine
program we would be in a situation that
india is facing right now or nepal is
facing right now where they're seeing
you know terrible surges and hospitals
overfilling and
and people dying on the streets now
we're not in that situation and that is
because of our vaccine program
but if you have a variable and this is
what the sage modeling subgroup shows
this is you know this
the government's own scientific advisors
showed if you have a variant
that is that is 50 more transmissible
even if the vaccines work just as well
as they do now even if you have really
high uptake which we do that's all in
the model
you can still get to a situation where
you overwhelm hospitals
and that's just because if you have an
incredibly large number of people
infected even a tiny percentage that
then gets sick and the vaccines aren't
perfect even three
three four percent is still enough to
create
to create stress on the nhs now if it's
just 20 or 30
more transmissible you're not going to
see that level
so that's kind of why it's really really
important that we pin down exactly how
much more transmissible it is
and we're told that we're going to have
that data in the coming weeks but one of
the issues that we have had over the
course of the pandemic
is that a lot of the modeling that's
taken place within sage within
government
has been based on worst case scenarios
and the lab data and real world data
that we continue to get
shows that the vaccines are far more
effective than often the modeling takes
into account
i know that you've been quite cautious
and nervous about the reopening that's
taken place so far
and certainly around the 21st of june
but if all the data continues to point
in the right direction
would there be any reason not to go
ahead with it so firstly the latest
stage modelings are not based on worst
case scenarios they use
up-to-date data from public health
england and the latest published
information in the new england journal
and the science you know
in science on vaccine efficacy they
assume
very very high vaccine fiscal efficacy
that comes directly
from our data they assume very high
vaccine uptake
which comes directly from our data and
it's because that data is better than
was expected in february and march that
their models are actually showing
um a much more limited search so under
the old under the kent variant if we
didn't have this new variant
their models are showing actually we
probably would be fine to open this
summer
because they're using actual real data
they're not modeling a worst case
scenario right now
now the new variant does change things
if
it comes to you know three weeks time in
cases are still going down
overall then yes i think we're in a
situation where you can say okay the new
variant turned out
not to be as bad as we feared we're in a
position where we can open further but
we don't know that yet because we're not
there yet
so that's that's all i'm saying i'm
saying you know we can't promise where
we're going to be in a few
a few weeks because that data's not here
yet
well i don't think anyone can promise
anything um over the course of this
pandemic we know that the
virus continues to surprise us but as
we're not expected to do the next phase
of reopening until the 21st of june
where do you really differ from the
government's projected timelines and
policies for reopening um
why did i say i differed what i differ
in
is saying that that we can we can
put a date on it and i don't think we
should say that the 21st of june is a
special date and that if we miss it it's
a big disaster
but i think where where i differ most on
are two things
one is international travel and our
border policy
so you know we saw that in january and
february we were very focused on
um on the brazilian and the south
african variants you know that
was the variants that were discovered
there and
we kind of had a red list and thought
that would keep them out and we
certainly have controlled those variants
in the uk they're very very low levels
and we just and then it turned out that
the next dangerous variant came from
india
we don't know where the next dangerous
variant is coming from covid is still
um running rampant in many countries
across the world
and many of them don't sequence right
and so it's not until too late that we
understand that there's a new barrier
that's arisen so i think this summer
while we're still
trying to finish vaccinating our
population is not the right summer to
have international travel
and risk new importations um the other
thing you say it's a
you say it's a dangerous variant but the
evidence
hasn't quite held that up yet i mean all
of the lab and real world
real-world data that we're getting about
the variant would suggest that vaccines
hold up against it and covid has mutated
many of thousands of times
so at what point do you think it would
be safe to
open up the borders more and to resume
some kind of normal international travel
is it about vaccination numbers is it
about covert levels when i said that it
is dangerous it is dangerous because it
is more transmissible
and that and that makes it harder to
keep it under control there's no
there's no doubt that even if it's just
ten percent more transmissible
we would be in a better position if it
wasn't here i mean
well indeed we'd be in a much better
position if we didn't
have the final evidence like the the the
deputy chair of jcvi
the government's vaccination
subcommittee he said that actually
it does resist the vaccines more than
the kent variant now
it seems to protect against severe
illness but you can get sick and you can
pass on if you're vaccinated now
what that means is that it's even it
makes it more transmissible right
because it means that you can pass it on
even if you don't personally get sick
we don't know what impact that will have
on long covered
we don't know if it will mutate further
given
given the the the opportunities here so
so i think
saying that any new variant that is
fitter than the last variant is a
dangerous occurrence
is true most mutations don't become
fitter they die out this one is not
dying out it's dominating in india it's
dominating in nepal
in every country it's been discovered
it's growing rapidly so it's kind of
it's the next ken variant if you like
now if we're lucky
it won't be fit enough to overcome our
vaccination program
covid is a dangerous virus variants
included
but we now see that cases are
decelerating or even declining in the
major outbreaks in the uk
cases also appear to be leveling off in
india
to go back to that original question
given the fact that we may be living
with variants
for years to come and indeed
indefinitely at what point would you say
you think we can start to resume
some normality when it comes to
international travel and perhaps some of
those
bigger decisions around large-scale
events and the complete removal of
social distancing
if this is something we're likely to
have to live with for a long time
i would like us to follow israel's
example where they
only opened up once they fully
vaccinated
and we're only about 35 fully vaccinated
of adults fully vaccinated um
about 75 80 percent of all adults in
israel and they're now vaccinating
adolescents and they're the only country
that's actually achieved
control of kovitz to almost zero levels
through vaccination
other countries with high vaccination
rates are still saying all about it
because they haven't got to that level
yet
and israel closed its borders entirely
while it was doing its vaccination
program and even now
has quite straight border controls and
even now still asks people to wear masks
inside and has masks inside schools
but they are reaping the benefits
because they've managed to open their
economy almost entirely
without seeing any kind of resurgence of
cable so that's what i would like to see
i'd like to see us get to the stage
where we have
vaccinated maybe 80 85 of all adults
fully
and have a plan for how we potentially
boost against variance and vaccinate
adolescents
um and that should be by september it's
not that far away
right and i think so for me 2022
let's open right that's fine you know
we'll know a lot more about variance
we'll have new vaccines
most of our population will be protected
we hopefully will be at least near the
um threshold where you can rely on
population immunity to
keep new outbreaks low and contained so
that that's how i see it
when you say let's open obviously the
opening process is phased
would you in your ideal scenario be
rolling back some of the reopening we've
done would you pause it here
or would you just continue to follow the
data in whichever direction it took us
i think i'd follow the data i mean at
the moment um
if it was up to me i would have delayed
monday's reopening
by a few weeks um until until we
actually did know more about this
variant now i think it's too late to
roll it back
um but i'll be watching the data really
carefully
and if it turns out it's fine then then
okay then we keep going
you know i'm not i'm not saying that
that in in falling cases we should
have more restrictions but i i do think
that the data is there to be concerned
right now and there are perfectly
reasonable explanations for why we're
not seeing
um an overall increase because we don't
have this variant being dominant yet
and we we're in a situation where one
variant's falling and the other fairy is
going up and they and they haven't
overtaken each other yet
back in early april you also warned
about the 12th of april reopening
telling the independent that we are
seeing the same things we saw last year
and in the autumn
none of the fundamentals have changed
but of course we saw schools reopen
shops outdoor hospitality more
households mixing outdoors
of course it's too early to say with the
17th of may reopening is going to do
but we just have not seen that national
surge in infection hospitalizations or
death
the opposite in fact so would you agree
that now that the fundamentals
have changed and that they are looking
more positive i never said that we were
going to have a surge in infections and
hospitalizations from
from that reopening and in fact the sage
models from february march said that the
dangerous
step was the step we've just taken to
may not the one in april what i said
what did you mean by the fundamentals i
said that there have been an increase
in cases in march in schools we didn't
we haven't seen that today
since april and i suspect that's because
community transmission actually did drop
a lot over easter which is really good
news
and we were quite lucky in that we had
quite nice easter weather so people
could go outside but we are now seeing
where cases are going up so in bolton
cases in school-aged children are higher
than they've ever been in the pandemic
they're
you know over 500 cases per 100 000 per
week
so it's not the case that everything's
always fine
when i we're talking about the
fundamentals what hasn't changed is that
even now
people are being asked to do rapid tests
that people are being asked to test
themselves all the time but there's no
real support for you
if you test positive there's very little
financial support and so little
financial incentive for people to get
tested if they can't afford to then
isolate at home it's also very
disruptive to your to your life to
carrying responsibilities to school
and so we are seeing that in
disadvantaged communities they are less
likely to come forward for testing and
less likely to isolate and have higher
rates of coverage
exposure through work and poorer housing
so we are seeing that there is this
disparity
between more well-off areas and less
well-off areas and so what worries me
then and worries me now is that actually
what we'll see is the covid becomes a
disease is very associated with poverty
and disadvantage and i think that could
be avoided
by providing more support to those
communities i suppose the difficult
thing is that
lockdowns um regardless of of of what
you think of them
um level down in in the most serious
sense and we know that they affect
the poor and the disadvantage the most
and it just comes down to that
very difficult trade-off doesn't it
about protecting people from the virus
you mentioned children there but also of
course the 20 000 children that we know
have
dropped out of school since lockdown's
hit
yeah i mean like no one no one thinks
lockdown is a good idea
and through good public health measures
you should be able to avoid lockdowns
now
when you get a situation where the virus
is increasing exponentially
that we had um in december for instance
and that you know india's just had and
other countries just had
and you have a situation where your
hospitals are overwhelmed and an
independent report that came out
yesterday said that actually yes the nhs
was overwhelmed
in january it means that no one can
access care in the way that you would
want them to access now that disrupts
your economy
it disrupts people's lives if you feel
like i'm not in a position to be able
to get care if i get sick it's going to
restrict your behaviors and so you do
then end up having to have these
lockdowns and the more it gets out of
control the longer you have to lock down
for
to get cases back down again whereas if
you prevent cases going up in the first
place
it's much more effective and that's been
you know
my advice the whole time is if you
actually did for instance support people
to isolate
then effectively all you're doing is
locking down people most likely to have
covid for a short period of time
letting the rest of the economy carry on
but we've never really done that so
we've ended up kind of opening
and then the cycle of restrictions and
no restrictions restrictions and no
restrictions i don't think that's
optimal health policy
and i never have but i do think that
when you have a virus that goes out of
control
and overwhelms your hospitals and your
health care
and actually affects the disadvantaged
communities much more who had rates of
covid you know twice three times the
most advantaged areas and suffered much
more
death and disability from it that that's
the problem and you have to deal with it
christina thank you for joining
spectator tv
[Music]
you